i'm shadow shea in windsor ontario at
the ambassador bridge and earlier this
morning police here from ontario
provincial police london police windsor
police the rcmp involved in dealing with
this blockade so these are some of the
officers here
right now that moved in earlier today
they started off by
sealing off one of the groups of
protesters here trucks and pickup trucks
and in in the main most of the truck
owners
agreed to leave they were told that they
had to leave they left voluntarily and
at this point there are still some
trucks that have not left but it's a
slow process here and in the last few
minutes or so some of the people have
started to
take on the police here tell the police
that they should stand down
that they should
back away
and that they
in fact
would be better off if they did that but
this gentleman here for one i ask you
all kindly
you're all way better than this
every one of you is way better than this
so the police are repositioning here uh
there's you know
hard to put a clear estimate on the
number police we've seen probably 150 or
so police officers here in uniform
there's also
armored personnel carrier behind uh
there are
police snipers on the roof of the
customs building here at the ambassador
bridge
lots of media here from the united
states as well as from canada
and
you know these are the faces of some of
the people that are still
talking to the police
trying to should be here compel the
police are trying to point out to the
police that they should leave like like
this gentleman here but of course the
police are
very well equipped here
there's the freedom
chat we've been hearing so much
[Music]
free country
this doesn't look like a free country it
doesn't look like a free country
you're better than this i know you're
better than that police are moving up
now
[Music]
police are moving up slowly sort of
and the
armored vehicle is coming forward right
now as well
[Music]
police are asking the
protesters to back up
we're kind of being pushed back
in the area of where the larger trucks
are situated
[Music]
this is actually uh
the closest the police have come the
police you know had had held back and it
was pretty easy for them to get
the first vehicles to agree to leave
this is the first real face-to-face
confrontation we're seeing
up close here
you guys are just gonna change your
murals thank you
no more shots no more lockdown
[Applause]
and we heard the
national anthem earlier and they're
breaking out in it again to now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
and that's where we stand right now sean
o'shea reporting from windsor ontario